[Música]
como cerraron los mercados y las
principales noticias destacadas para
este cierre de semana aquí en economía
está con nosotros jorge hurtado para
conocer los detalles vamos a hablar
entonces jorge de la economía en eeuu y
hablaremos de la situación del empleo
qué sucede allí vamos a dedicar de hecho
toda la crónica a este tema tan
importante y buena si hay malas noticias
buenas porque el índice de desempleo se
ubicó en abril en eeuu en el 3.6 por
ciento de la fuerza laboral el más bajo
desde la pandemia pero las malas
noticias son por los retos en la
contratación que contrae hasta marzo ese
país registró un récord de 11,5 millones
de puestos de trabajo es decir dos
vacantes por cada desempleado pero el
empleo en el sector del ocio y la
hostelería ha descendido un 1,5 millones
o sea un 87 por ciento desde febrero de
2020 según la oficina de estadísticas
laborales para entender las causas de
este extraño desequilibrio del mercado
laboral en eeuu conversamos antes con
alberto bernal leonel director de
estrategia global de xp investment
especialmente a el hecho de que después
de la caída tan brutal que se vivió
durante la pandemia
la economía de eeuu y la verdad sea
dicha casi todos los países alrededor
del mundo tuvieron una reactivación
económica muchísimo más significativa
comparado con las expectativas y esto
también se desee pues también concluyó
con el hecho de que el gobierno de eeuu
tomó decisiones de expansión del gasto
público muy fuertes para tratar de
ayudarle a las personas que habían
perdido su empleo y el banco central de
eeuu también tomó decisiones de
incrementar los niveles de liquidez y
bajar las tasas de interés a una forma
muy de una forma muy importante eso por
el lado de incrementar la actividad
económica y también un fenómeno bastante
interesante que es que todavía hay
muchas personas que siguen por fuera de
las fuerzas laboral en eeuu más o menos
unos 3 millones de personas todavía no
se han devuelto
a la fuerza laboral
porque pero quienes más padecen de este
desequilibrio son las pequeñas empresas
allí en eeuu que es lo que pasa santiago
y es que contratar y retener a los
empleados sigue siendo el principal reto
para las pequeñas empresas según una
encuesta de golman sachs los datos
revelan que el 90% de las empresas que
contratan tienen dificultades para
reclutar candidatos cualificados para
los puestos vacantes y ahora compiten
con las grandes compañías para ofrecer
mejores salarios 42 por ciento de los
pequeños negocios afirman que han
perdido empleados porque las empresas
más grandes ofrecen mejores salarios
pero esos mejores salarios también son
un peligro para la inflación más alta en
cuatro décadas que vive ese país esto
dijo nuestro invitado al respecto es
pasado
se perdieron empleos dentro de las
empresas de 0 a 50 personas y esto es va
exactamente por el lado de lo que tú es
de lo que tú estás hablando que pues las
empresas más grandes tienen más
capacidad financiera y entonces logran
convencer a los empleados que se vayan a
trabajar en esas empresas más grandes y
dejan en una situación bastante difícil
a los pequeños negocios entonces pues
digamos esto es muy buena noticia para
las persona que dependen de su salario y
es complicado para los dueños de
negocios que pueden hacer estas empresas
más pequeñas pues desafortunadamente
nada diferente a tratar de retener a
esos empleados y para tratar de retener
a sus empleados pues obviamente se
necesita dar mejores condiciones y esas
mejores condiciones cuesta entonces se
le incrementan los costos de
funcionamiento de las pequeñas empresas
y esto es uno de los temas que pues
obviamente generan preocupación desde el
punto de vista de los dueños de estas
empresas porque teniendo claro ya este
panorama entonces cuáles pueden ser las
soluciones a esta situación por ejemplo
algunas empresas han recurrido a la
tecnología cómo sustituir a un cajero
humano por una máquina otros ofrecen
ahora mejores salarios incentivos y
hasta becas para llenar la vacante según
nuestro invitado los mayores ganadores
por ahora en esta situación son los
trabajadores
claro
yo pienso que para esto es una gran
noticia para para los trabajadores de
eeuu hay que decirlo en los últimos 25 o
30 años han sido muy buenos años para
las empresas y para los dueños de las
empresas y no tanto para los
trabajadores y yo creo que desde el
inicio de la pandemia se ha visto una
reversa de eso y él y los mayores
beneficiados en este momento de lo que
ha pasado este post kobe es
definitivamente la clase trabajadora no
después enhorabuena es una gran noticia
para los trabajadores de eeuu que estén
viendo un incremento en su en su ingreso
y pues lo importante acá es mantener
esas políticas pro mercado por negocios
provee empleo para que se pueda mantener
muchísimo más tiempo la economía eeuu en
lo que yo considero es el máximo del
nivel de empleo posible que es el que se
está viendo en este momento porque no
hay peor tragedia que el desempleo
muchas gracias jorge por esta
actualización del mundo económico no se
vaya muy lejos ustedes tampoco
televidentes porque ya está esto es para
kobe 19 en la semana en américa
[Música]